taylor swift whisked us away into a
fairy tale with her ethereal grammy
performance on sunday night
[Music]
swift performed a medley of cardigan
august and
willow from her latest sister albums
folklore and evermore
[Music]
she was joined on stage by her
collaborators jack antonoff and the
nationals aaron destner
solidifying that we absolutely cannot
wait to be in the crowd of her next tour
this has been an adventure that the
three of us have gone on since the very
beginning of
quarantine and lockdown and you know
we've only gotten to be
together in the same room
once and so this is really
awesome to get to be together with them
again we're quarantining in the same
house
for the whole week we're tested every
day so it's just really exciting
honestly to play music with your
collaborators that's
something that i will never ever take
for granted again this year is yet
another grammy milestone for taylor who
was up for six awards at sunday night's
show
and took home the night's big award
album of the year for folklore
thanking her boyfriend joe alwyn in her
winning speech
joe who is the first person that i play
every single song that i write and and
i had the best time writing songs with
you in quarantine we caught up with her
just days before music's biggest night
how crazy is it that you are
re-recording all of your songs
on the 13th anniversary of your first
ever grammy nomination i know 13 is your
favorite number so what would you tell
that girl during her first grammy
nomination about the next 13 years of
her career
so your question is a great one um it is
pretty wild how much time has passed
since my first grammy nomination and
i still feel really lucky to have a
chance to be a part of this night
and um i think the advice i would give
myself
when i was younger is probably to when
things
get hard always focus
in on how much i love music
that has been the thing that no matter
what has protected me from any
of the other outside things that have
made me feel strange you know
um i've never had a problem with
the general fact of of making music or
playing music i've never stopped loving
it
it's been the outside stuff um you know
that has made me feel down at times but
i think there are two things that have
protected me over the course of
my career and the first thing is
enthusiasm
and the second thing is how much i love
music
enthusiasm as soon as you
fail enthusiasm tells you that
the next great idea is around the corner
and
your love of music will always center
your you if you're doing
this for that and that alone because
that is hard to take away you know
people can reduce and criticize other
elements but the fact that
it sounds really really simple but
loving the actual
the actual making of music and the
playing of music is is what i think has
really
helped me balance things thanks for the
question